hey everybody today I'm going to be
showing you something real simple but
something that I didn't necessarily know
how to do the first time I fired up GTA
5 for the PC so one of the benefits of
having grand theft auto on a PC is that
you can import your own music into the
game and use it as a radio station all
you'll need to do to have your own music
populate the self radio option is open
up the folder on windows containing your
PC in this case it's called this PC then
open documents rockstar games
GTA 5 user music either move or copy
your music to this folder and then fire
up GTA from here all you need to do is
open up audio options scan your music
folder and then set the radio to the
preference of your choice there's an
option to play your songs sequentially
in a random order or in typical GTA
radio style with ads peppered in between
in this example I've used all dot wav
files which worked perfectly but mp3 m4a
and most audio extensions should work
here if you're having any trouble there
are a number of sites where you can
convert your music to just about any
file format imaginable so that's really
all there is to it
dump your music in the folder fire up
GTA and get down to business
you